hey youtubers is Charlie so Jason Momoa
as he does was spotted pounding beers in
Ireland near where they're doing Game of
Thrones Season seven pre-production this
is gonna be a breakdown of what's going
on especially what's going to be
happening with a Dothraki next season
it'd be so awesome if we got some more
Khal Drogo flashbacks but I think really
what's going on here you have to imagine
Jason Momoa is working on Justice League
and this other person here in this
picture is Brian Mendoza one of the
people that's working on another
different film with Jason Momoa so
they're basically just like him hanging
out with friends he's probably on a
production break and just using the time
to have fun or o'clock in on other
projects he could totally appear in a
Game of Thrones Season seven flashback
but largely what I'm expecting from the
Dothraki story in season seven and I
know you're like we haven't really
talked too much about the Dothraki is
like a little bit of comedy about them
having to pass over the water they
didn't really address it like it was
kind of an offhanded thing but Dothraki
deathly afraid of water
so imagine how hard it was for them to
load all the horses and all the people
onto those ships is Daenerys is sailing
to Westeros but I would just expect them
to have a little bit of fun like with
Tyrians character just because so much
comedy flow through Tyrion of him trying
to organize the Dothraki as they load
and unload and move towards King's
Landing
so just expecting them to have some fun
with that and I'm also kind of expecting
for a grey worm type character to rise
up like grey worm is kind of the
representative of the unsullied like
there were scenes during season six
where we saw a bunch of unsullied all
fighting on screen but when you need to
interact with them usually grey worm is
the proxy for that so he's kind of like
the sub commander under Daenerys in the
small Council of the unsullied I feel
like there's going to be somebody to do
that for the Dothraki normally it'd be
Daario but he did not make the trip to
Westeros with them he's back in the bay
of dragons is like the mayor of Murray
living in the pyramid now so we need a
couple Dothraki characters to be sub
commanders under Khaleesi but like when
Dan and Dave were previewing season
seven like I did my last video where I
kind of read what they were saying about
Daenerys about how she has all these
amazing forces what could possibly go
wrong meaning that it will definitely go
wrong for her I feel like she'll have
some problems
trying to organize all these people like
once Dothraki are on horseback in an
open field they're almost unstoppable
unsullied some of the best if not the
best fighters in the world I just feel
like the only way that the riders can
throw rocks at that is to like cause
some problems while they're actually
trying to transport all those troops up
to King's Landing or in the actual field
of battle there's something really
interesting in the books like when you
read about the history of how Aegon was
conquering the Seven Kingdoms how he was
not able to conquer door because when he
took his dragons in his troops down to
Dorne just the terrain was too hard for
him to fight in the Dornish people were
able to use that to their advantage to
force them off so we might see a version
of that happening when Daenerys tries to
attack in Westeros like people using the
terrain against her because the Dothraki
the unsullied are used to very specific
conditions you guys can let me know what
you think but they're like only a couple
big problems that you can throw at
armies like the nurses like they could
have food problems they could have
disease problems they could have
problems fighting under conditions that
are not used to like Daenerys dragons
are very powerful so like if they're
sailing at sea and Euron is able to
strafe them he could take a lot of them
out before the dragons take down you're
on ships and you're on is supposedly
building a thousand ships so even if the
dragons were to strafe all of your on
ships he would still be able to take out
a giant portion of Daenerys fleet
wallets at sea so you guys can let me
know you think how do you think the
writers are gonna create problems for
Daenerys as army I mean there's always
wildfire - I feel like sir she's gonna
find some more wildfire we could see
them flirt with a Blackwater esque type
episode where she rolls up and Cersei
tries to do a version of what Tyrion did
I still feel like if TV show Daenerys is
immune to fire though she'll be immune
to wildfire but that's just them the
rest of the fleet all the ships all the
people all the horses can definitely be
burned by a wildfire so really like the
biggest problems for Daenerys right now
are feeding her army in actually getting
them to the place where they need to
fight without being molested at sea by
Euron but it is always awesome to see
Khal Drogo chilling out with all the
other Game of Thrones actors he is like
the most chill dude and Holly
there's a Kevin Smith told a funny story
about him how he used to be this athlete
but hurt himself so he became an actor
instead and Kevin Smith was like do you
ever wish sometimes that you maybe you
hadn't hurt yourself and you'd be a
professional athlete and like this was
while Jason Momoa was getting ready to
go work on Justice League
in Momoa was just like hell no dude this
is the greatest thing that ever happened
to me so let it be known that if you
ever catch Khal Drogo in the wild he
will probably be willing to have a beer
with you that's actually another good
question let me know in the comments do
any of you have a Jason Momoa spotted in
the wild story like have you ever run
into him at a bar before but if you guys
didn't know there is a new round of the
giveaway that's going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video if
there's any other bonus videos like any
Dothraki videos that you guys want me to
do just let me know in the comments I'm
really interested to see what they do
with them in season seven but a lot of
the big Dothraki characters from the
books have either been killed off or
just been skipped over so it seems like
whatever Dothraki stuff the show does
will be original to the TV show it'll be
something that they come up with well
you guys wait for my next video you can
click here for Danny Dave's big preview
for season seven what they're saying
about all the big storylines and you can
click here for the season seven teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you